listen it's dad's birthday come on be
good to him be good to him
come on everybody it's dad's birthday
come on come on come on okay i'm gonna
bring you here so i don't have to we
don't have to reach let's get all the
crew here i want to see everybody and
elise get in here too listen to him sing
to you yeah it means so much you look so
beautiful you do too look y'all are
listen this is the crew tonight i love
this you got everybody here you made
everybody come with dad it's all about
it's all about the family man and when
you talk about this movie you're going
to feel that family aspect you're going
to see these incredible characters and
tom holland's characters zendaya's
character on what it takes to get
through everything and it's just it's
amazing
oh look at this this is a good one some
suggest that parker's powers include the
male spider's ability to hypnotize
females stop come on yes my spider lord
and it's my birthday it is your birthday
come on
and so we're here to celebrate yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so these are my gifts these are my my
kids we do everything for them and the
way they develop so that's why they're
here can i show you can i give you a
little birthday gift take you back to
the very first spider-man premiere
look at that
look at that
look at this
look at this right here
that's so cool
i think it's amazing and if you if you
were able to see how these kids have
developed
and how smart they are and how humble
they are respectful they are you know
they get a chance to do a lot of these
great things they're very respectful and
then my beautiful daughter there she
looks
bananas
bananas
look at this my beautiful daughter's
just killing they all beauty just go
ahead
karen i mean how proud of all all of you
of jamie tonight i mean we're so proud
of him you're all right you spiderman
yeah costume gives it away huh but this
is pretty important max how do you know
my name
it's written on your badge see out there
i remember him doing the first
spider-man and going to set and going to
atlanta and so all these years later to
see him doing it again i'm so proud and
i'm so excited to see it yeah absolutely
jamie come back here for one last
question before we let you guys go so
next year
marks the 30th anniversary of your very
first film credit for the movie toys
back in 1992
zebo captain xevo come in
come in can i have your position
that's an inappropriate question at this
time baker oh we have a position
report please
he's at the residence of miss tyler what
do you remember about shooting that and
then thinking you've been doing this for
30 strong yeah what i remember about
that is i didn't have any lines
but i'm gonna tell you what was great i
got a chance to watch a great
robin williams i watched him
do one line 13 different times 13
different ways
and it taught me so whenever i get my
chance to really go i'm gonna make sure
that i push everything to the limit and
because of situations like that uh
we're still here doing it and now i'm
dirty you're an oscar winner yeah but
you've done it all my man and it's been
incredible and then like i said to have
annalise come here come on
come
and then to have two beautiful talented
come over this way
two beautiful talented daughters
that are picking up
right where i started or left off she
sold the show to abc
she's written her own anime does music
she's running our company
so i'm proud of these beautiful ladies
right here
congratulations
that's it
that's it i love when you get emotional
about your babies i love when i forgot i
cry a lot
but i'm so i'm so proud of both of them
and it's just amazing to be here tonight
and thank you
you